good morning everyone and welcome to the
primary and acquired resistance to
cancer immunotherapy session at the
immune oncology event
i'm leonisola a medical doctor and
scientist at the parker institute for
cancer immunotherapy
and i'm a former md anderson fellow
my work today focuses on clinical
development accelerating research
and exploring novel approaches to tackle
cancer with immunotherapy at pisces
one of the main challenges in cancer
immunotherapy is
the resistance to io therapies primary
resistance can occur
before treatment and acquired resistance
can occur in patients who responded to
treatment
but relapsed after a period of
effectiveness
most cancer patients will develop
primary resistance to checkpoint
inhibitors
while 40 of those who don't have primary
resistance
have an objective response although
immunotherapy can induce tumor cell
death and provoke significant clinical
results
there are still unknown mechanisms
that limit the application of cancer
immunotherapy
i have no actual or potential conflict
of interest in relationship to this
program
or presentation and i'm speaking on
behalf of the parker institute of cancer
immunotherapy
some high level topics that we'll be
covering in this talk today
are related to the progress that we've
made in immunotherapy
what are the different types of
resistance and the strategies
with in which we are approaching
immunoresistance
um through the years
we have made a lot of advances in
immunotherapy
and focusing specifically on immune
checkpoint therapy
monoclonal antibodies targeting code
stimulatory
immune checkpoints such as pd-1 and
ctla-4
have demonstrated clinical activity in
several malignancies
including melanoma non-small cell lung
cancer renal cell carcinoma
bladder cancer head and neck
squamous cell carcinoma msi high
colorectal carcinoma markov cell
carcinoma and so on clearly
immunotherapy has changed
the practice of medical oncology and i
think in the past year
we saw an approval in breast cancer for
the first time which is
very exciting especially because
for many people we are treating breast
cancer
previously and in prior trials clinical
efficacy in immunotherapy did not go so
well
so it was a very happy moment to see
that happening last year for
breast cancer patients checkpoint
inhibitors have transformed cancer
treatment
but many patients still do not respond
to it
human-derived multi-omics studies have
shown
immunological distinct class of
resistance to pd1 therapy and future
work should focus on understanding
immune surveillance
at a single cell level
patients who have primary resistance to
checkpoint inhibitors
do not respond to initial therapy
ongoing
studies indicate that both tumor cell
intransic and tumor cell extrinsic
factors
contribute to resistance mechanism and
the most straightforward reason why a
tumor would not respond to immune
checkpoint therapy
is the lack of recognition by t cells
because of the absence of tumor antigens
alternatively cancer cells may have
tumor antigens
but develop mechanisms to avoid
presenting them
on the surface restricted by mhc due to
the alterations in the antigen
presenting machinery
early trials with monoclonal antibodies
targeting
pd-1 and pdl-1 have demonstrated durable
clinical responses in patients with
non-small lung cancer however
current assays for the prognostic and
predictive role
of pd pdl1 expression are not
standardized with respect to either
quantity
or distribution of expression
objective determination of pdl-1
proteins reviews
heterogeneity within tumors and
from prominent inter-acid variability or
discordance
this could be due to different antibody
affinities
limiting specificity specificity or
distinct target
epitopes efforts to determine the
clinical value of those
observations are underway but we know
that pd-1 expression
is heterogeneous pdl1
is mainly expressed on the surface of
tumor cells
and antigen presenting cells in various
malignancies
such as squamous carcinoma carcinomas of
the brain
gi tract bladder ovary
and the skin in the tumor micro
environment
pdl-1 expression on tumor cells and
other tumor-promoting cells
is caused by two mechanisms constitutive
mechanism
and induced mechanism both of which
depend on the binding sites of
irf1 for example praf
mutated melanoma the pdl1 expression is
a result of cancer cells adaptive
response to immune attack
evoked by cytokines or a constitutive
expression
which is a result of oncogenic processes
pdl1 is rarely expressed on normal
tissues
but inducibly expressed on tumor site
which makes pdl-1 pathway
uniquely different from any
co-inhibitory pathways
indicating that the selective expression
of pdl1
may have some association with clinical
outcomes for cancer patients
and can be a selective target for
anti-tumor therapy
so dissecting the tumor microenvironment
during disease regression and
progression
could show us a little bit more of that
understanding
as you can see in this picture a
expression scores
of genes related to tumor
microenvironment
immune cell types or even immune cell
states
the blue backgrounds indicate biopsies
taken during disease regression
and orange backgrounds indicate biopsies
taken during disease progression
on picture b samples for each time point
from um from tumor were
stained with specific antibodies against
cd8 and or cd4 and were quantified
using a cell counter function
boxes in the upper panels are shown
at a higher magnification in the lower
panels
advancing treatment option options for
patients with primary resistance to
immunotherapy requires a pursuit of
understanding
of what are the biomarker subtypes of
resistance
to pd-1 therapy or how
are these biomarkers different across
cancer times
types and treatment regimens
and we need to have a clearer
understanding if the body of knowledge
that we have
developed would allow us
to understand the related toxicities and
the association with resistance to pd1
therapy
identifying the potential relationship
between the tumor
microenvironment the tumor mutational
landscape
and the pd-1 resistance could help us
develop
such biomarkers and perhaps create a
predictive model for toxicity
and iras
here some basic signs that led us to
where we are
in terms of immune checkpoint blockade
and as many
of you are no doubt aware engaging a
t-cell response is a multi-step
process and it really involves at the
very least
the interaction of a t cell with an
antigen presenting cell
after the t cell becomes activated ctla4
for example translocates
from this intracellular restore into the
immune synapse
where it binds in fact with 20 fold
higher ability
to the same cois stimulatory molecules
that
cd8 20 28 does
and instead of generating a positive
signal like cd828
it generates a negative signal and so
with that knowledge in hand
jim allison theorized that if you would
block ctla4
such as with an antibody you would allow
a t cell to become more proliferative
and more activated than normal
this sort of physiological governance
allowed and really led
the hypothesis of antibody based immune
checkpoint blockade
to the first agent of its class
immune checkpoint inhibitor therapy has
been
particularly successful in melanoma for
which approved therapies
include pd1 atpd-1
ctla4 and the combination of both
regiments
long-term survival data for patients
with melanoma treated with evilly lab
indicates 20 of patients show
evidence of continued durable disease
control or response
after five to ten years after starting
therapy
the response rate for melanoma patients
treated with temporalisomap
was 33 at three years with 70 percent
of patients initially responding
maintaining a clinical response
as we saw on a paper from uh tony ribas
in 2016.
combination therapy or dual immune
checkpoint blockade has recently shown
dramatic responses in patients with
metastatic melanoma with rr
of 58 however half of patients
experience significant toxicity from the
treatment regimen and survival benefit
for this approach
has to be demonstrated
the incidence of metastatic melanoma has
increased
over the past three decades regulatory
pathways that limit
the immune response to cancer are
becoming increasingly well characterized
cytotoxic this lymphocyte associated
antigen 4 is an immune checkpoint
molecule that down regulates pathways
to t cell activation this fully human
monoclonal antibody that blocks ctle4
promotes antitumor immunity and has
shown activity in patients
with multi tumor types including
melanoma
challenges remain in defining what
responders and non-responders
are especially given the heterogeneity
in patterns
of response with checkpoint inhibitors
such
heterogeneity can be spatial meaning a
different response in different lesions
or temporal
or stable disease followed by
progression
manifesting within a given
patient makes responses oligometastatic
progression
and or stable disease with isolated
progression can be seen as well
and despite these complexities detail on
the survival curve suggests that
long-term disease control
is possible in a significant proportion
of patients
successfully treated with checkpoint
inhibitors
this possibility of expanding this
long-term clinical benefit to more
patients with advanced cancer is thus
fueling more and more
investigation into the elusive
mechanisms of response
and resistance to this therapy
patients who have primary resistance to
checkpoint inhibitors do not respond to
initial therapy
and ongoing studies indicate that both
tumor
centric cell centric and tumor cell
extrinsic
factors contribute to these resistance
mechanisms
the most straightforward reason why a
tumor would not respond to immune
checkpoint therapy is the lack of
recognition by t
cells because of the absence of tumor
antigens
alternatively cancer cells may have
tumor antigens but develop mechanisms to
avoid presenting them
on the surface restricted by mhc
the cell intrinsic factors that
contribute to
immunotherapy resistance include
expression or
repression of certain genes and pathways
in tumor cells
that prevent immune cell infiltration or
function within the tumor micro
environment
these mechanisms may exist at
the initial time of presentation which
highlight primary resistance mechanisms
or this mechanism may evolve later which
will will be highlighted by the adaptive
resistance
mechanisms multiple tumor intrinsic
mechanisms
have recently been identified and they
include signaling through
the myogen activated protein kinase
pathway
or the loss of ptn expression which
enhances
pi3k signaling or the expression
of wnt beta ketone signaling pathway
or the loss of interferon gamma
signaling pathway or the lack of the t
cell response
due to the loss of the tumor antigen
expression
oncogenic signaling through
this pathway results in the production
of
vgf and r io8
among many other secreted proteins
which have known inhibitory effects on
the t
cell recruitment and function similarly
the loss of p10 which enhances p
i 3k signaling and its
most common phenomenon across several
cancers including 30
of melanomas was found to be associated
with the resistance to
immune checkpoint therapy
importantly the frequency of p10
deletions
and the mutations was higher in
non-t cell inflamed tumors as compared
to t-cell inflamed tumors
in addition marine models lacking better
ketone responded effectively to immune
checkpoint therapy
whilst be better kettening positive
tumors did not
non t cell inflamed human melanoma
tumors which
lack t cells and cd 103
dendritic cells in the tumor
microenvironment had significantly
expressed
higher expression of tumor beta-carotene
signaling genes
cancer cells that constitutively express
immune suppressive cell
surfaces ligands like pdl-1 may
actively inhibit anti-tumor t-cell
responses
tumor cell extrinsic mechanisms that
lead
to primary and adaptive resistance
involves components other than tumor
cells within the tumor microenvironment
including regulatory t-rex myeloid
derived suppressor cells
macrophages and other inhibitory
checkpoint
in immune checkpoints
which may all contribute to the
inhibition of anti-tumor
immune responses regulatory t
cells which can be identified by
expression of fox p3
and transcription factor have a central
role in maintaining
self-tolerance the existence of
suppressor t
cells could down regulate immune
responses
of an antigen-specific t cells and it
was first identified nearly four decades
ago
published data indicate that many human
tumors are amputated by t-rex
and i wanted to highlight some of the
pisces projects that are trying to
tackle this understanding
of immune resistance
first this exploratory study with
nivolumab
with or without epilemumab according to
the percentage
of tumor cd8 cells in patients with
advanced metastatic cancer
in this prospective study patients will
first undergo a tumor biopsies
in patients with a higher concentration
of t
cells will receive a single checkpoint
inhibitor an evolution map
patients with a lower concentration of t
cells given
a cold tumor will undergo a combination
of nivolumab
plus epilin amount through a battery of
tests
which include gene sequencing protein
analysis imaging
and gut microbiome analysis we will
evaluate
how the immune system is changing before
during and after treatment
this uniquely comprehensive collection
of biomarker data
will allow us to create a heat map of
cancers
and of the cancer and it could guide us
uh further studies and potential
treatments in the future
here this is a unique collaboration
between the parker institute
bms cri and biotech parker
partner apexigen it's a phase 1b
to study evaluating the safety and
efficacy of cd4
antibiotic uh nivolumab
and chemotherapy the study first opened
in july 2017
and this immunotherapy combination
has shown preliminary results
demonstrating encouraging clinical
activity across
cohorts and first-line metastatic
pancreatic adenocarcinoma
here we are seeing a prostate cancer
platform study and as you know prostate
cancer is
a immune desert so given this tumor
is called we are approaching different
multiple
drug immunotherapy combinations first
activating the immune system with
pegulated io2
by enhancing the number of tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes
and perhaps overcoming adaptive immune
resistance
with the backbone of ntpd-1
another approach is inducing immunogel
immunogenic cell death
with radiotherapy by immobilizing and
activating
dendritic cell uh dendritic cells with a
flea3 ligand
and stimulating the immune system with a
pnp adjuvant
and to the right we see
a dna based vaccine with three plasmids
delivered by electroporation
il-12 psa and psma
and the overarching idea here is to
mobilize and activate dendritic cells
drive killer cd8 t cells
and perhaps turn
this cold tumor into a hot tumor with
immune infiltrate
last year on march 8th the fda granted
an accelerated approval
to a tesoluzumab in combination with
pathway tax cell protein
for adult patients with unresectable
locally advanced
or metastatic triple negative breast
cancer whose tumors
express pdl1 in patients with tumors
tested positive for the expression of
pdl1
the median overall survival tesoluzumab
was 25 months compared with 18 months
for those who received
nab pack pretaxo and placebo disapproval
for a tesla zoomab used in combination
with chemotherapy
is a great win for breast cancer
research
and an extraordinary win for
immunotherapy
however treatment response for cancers
to immunotherapy is
very difficult to predict positron
emission tomography
imaging may help to predict this
treatment response
uh pat will evaluate immunotherapy
targets and markers of immune activation
has shown some promises in early
clinical trials
antibodies and small molecules have used
pet for
different imaging characteristics and
clearly more studies are needed to
better interpret
and valid validate pet scans for this
purpose
biotech companies such as imagine app
are
developing a pipeline of imaging
products that leverage the
exquisite specificity of monoclonal
antibodies
and create precise images of disease
activity
so scientists have re-engineered
antibodies into fragments called meaning
bodies
and those are linked to a radio radio
isotope
to enable a safe and rapid detailed
illumination of the targeted cells
this ensures that the mini body is inert
and it doesn't exert any additional
effects on the body aside from
eliminating these relevant targets so
patients on this
clinical trials have been receiving
imaging agents
prior to a routine full body scan with
pet
and this technology would produce images
that provide a full body view of the
disease activity and the drug response
which could offer important insights at
a critical point
of the patient journey
this particular investigation cd8
positron emission tomography tracer is
certain
zirconium 89's uh
zr which is in clinical studies
um has have demonstrated to have an
acceptable
safety uh profile and to be
a safety a sensitive pad agent that has
the potential to detect the presence of
cda cells
in tumor and t cell rich tissues as a
tumor agnostic biomarker
biomarkers are very important
especially because they help us guide
and select
patients according to their tumors and
what the treatments
may work best for them and i think this
all came about in an era of genomics uh
genomic medicine where we were really
basing our treatment strategies on
specific mutations within a patient's
tumor and it has been something that
we've been
struggling a little bit in the
immunotherapy world because the immune
response is so dynamic
part of developing therapeutics is
the need to identify patients who will
respond to treatment
thus to advance drug development in
precision medicine there is a need to
develop technologies that are more
objective and quantitative through the
collection and
integration of larger data sets
multiplex ion beam imaging is a novel
imaging technology and these methods
characterize the prevalence location and
expression of relevant biomarkers
that are critical to the successes of
targeted therapies
there's also some anecdotal evidence for
all pd1
ntpd1 and ntpdl1 therapeutics that
patients negatively
negative for these biomarkers by ihc
respond to treatment
indicating again that multiple markers
and
quantitation will be needed to capture
ideal responders
however chromogenic staining is fraught
with serious drawbacks that influence
scoring
which is why additionally
we need to expand those investigations
into the integration of larger data sets
and maybe works well for that
t-cell response to checkpoint blockade
relies on the expansion of a distinct
t-cell repertoire
that may have only recently entered the
tumor however
whether the t-cell responds to
checkpoint blockade relies on
re-invigoration of pre-existing tumor
infiltrating lymphocytes
or on the recruitment of t novel t cells
remains unclear
tracking a t-cell receptor clones and
transcriptional
phenotypes revealed coupling with tumor
recognition clonal expansion and t cell
dysfunction
marked by clonal expansion of cd8 t
cells which co express markers on the
chronic t cell activation
and exhaustion
there are significant efforts underway
to identify
reliably predictive biomarkers of
response and resistance to checkpoint
inhibitors
in baseline tumor biopsies in patients
on immune checkpoint blockade
to date the best predictive biomarkers
identified
include total mutational load
as well as the markers on an effective
immune infrared within a tumor
signifying a hot tumor
micro environment typified by the
increased number of
cytotoxic t cells lymphocytes in
proximity
to the pdo1 positive cells
mutational load is highly relevant
as tumors with a higher mutational load
exhibit higher levels of neoantigens
capable
of inducing anti-tumor immune responses
and
translating into a higher likelihood of
response premium checkpoint blockade
across
several cancer types integrative
approaches
in incorporating analysis of several of
those features have also been developed
such as a cancer immunogram which
incorporates analysis of seven distinct
features within the tumor
microenvironment
tumor sensitivity to immune effectors
tumor fouriness
general immune status immune cell
activation
infiltration abscess of checkpoint
molecule expression
absence of soluble inhibitors such as
interleukin 1 or
6 or the absence of inhibitory tumor
metabolisms an emerging strategies
in elucidating mechanisms of response
and resistance to
immune checkpoint blockade involves the
assessment of
longitudinal tumor samples throughout
the course of treatment
so here i end my talk um thank you for
for watching um our discussion
uh please feel free to send my way
questions or comments
um and i would just like to give a shout
out to our
clinical development super team at the
parker institute
and even in challenging times such as
those that we are living now
we are working at full steam to speed up
science and deliver clinical trials to
academic centers
across the country while we are working
remotely we continue connected
pushing signs forward one clinical study
at a time
and a great thank you to all of our
academic centers
that are in the trenches with patients
taking on
the toughest cancer types as we usually
say
back at pisces central cancer fear spicy
thank you